[Music]
hey welcome to australia's commentaries
live from the italian riviera i am
spencer j gilbert i'm here with lon
harris danielle radford and when i say
live it's live yesterday
so this is a pre-tape uh normally we'd
give you our thoughts
about the trailer uh behind the scenes
stuff give you some outtakes
and respond to questions and comments
from viewers like you but it hasn't even
come out yet so we're gonna either make
some questions up or i will make uh
lawn play the part of annoying audience
member and ask as many questions as
possible
and then we will move on to a teaser for
uh next week's honest trailer which
should be
a crazy one but first luke luca
uh not that crazy kind of a simple
straightforward
um pixar i don't want to say good
dinosaur level but like a
mid to above pixar movie that i
thoroughly enjoyed but i'm probably
gonna forget about uh what did you guys
think of luca
yeah it's a mid but it's a sweet mid you
know i love mids
i love mids you know sometimes you just
want a mid you don't want the whole
thing you don't want to go too crazy
sometimes pixar's you know
strains of pixar have gotten too strong
and you want to just have something
yeah seeds are still in this one you go
for a nice hybrid pixar i don't know if
we were ready for a sativa pixar this
morning
a little bit of a cbd yeah yeah
you seem to have really hated this movie
well i do i do bring the knives out for
the honest trailer notes so it was a
little it was a little harsher than if
you just asked me on the street
but uh but yeah i i was a little i was a
little disappointed this to me feels
like
this would be a real good dreamworks
move
animation movie like like it it does not
feel like it really has that it's a good
story well told
the animation once again as always gotta
say it
beautiful the the shading and the way
that it uses like the
the natural looking light and this whole
beach town and
water effects once again like all that
stuff looks fantastic i got no
complaints
but in terms of the storytelling yeah it
feels very simple it feels kind of
superficial at times like
i just didn't feel like they had as good
a handle on what this
world was especially the the world under
the sea of the sea monsters and that
kind of makes it feel not to use a water
pump but shallow
in some ways uh so yeah it's
disappointing for
pixar only because they've set this
ridiculously high
crazy standard and i don't feel like
it's up to the level of
a cocoa or an inside out or something
that's more on that one
okay well fair enough let's get into our
detailed thoughts as we dive
deep uh into the shallows of
the lucanas trailer we're far from the
shallows
[Music]
hey look at that
gave you an existential crisis now the
studio that loves to make children stare
death in the face
asks audiences to consider what if two
fish boys had a fun summer together
okay cuz uh cause i could not handle
another coco right now
[Music]
um i mean this is a this is like a
honest commentary within the honest
commentary but i don't see us doing
soul anytime soon but we never talked
about seoul what'd you guys think of
seoul
i i didn't watch seoul because i like it
much as we say in the thing i was not
ready to have
my soul crush like i was not ready to
feel feelings when soul came out because
it was like right in the pandemic and i
was like oh
feelings no thank you so i went ahead
and skipped it
i was very happy that luca was just like
oh this is just a fun fish story i like
this
i don't have to feel or invest at all
yeah yeah i
uh the first time i watched seoul i i
did not love it
uh it really took another viewing for it
to like sort of click into place but
after i watched it a second time i
really did enjoy it and
the only thing i don't like is there's
like this whole subplot
where there's like these hippies that
figured out how to like
meditate and they could cross over to
like the world of
souls it's like their god basically and
it's such a
dumb shticky thing in the middle of this
otherwise very like
thoughtful interesting story that i
really hate that stuff it bugs me
every time it comes out but other than
that i really liked soul yeah
yeah i did too um i think again the
animation incredible in
a different way than luca was like they
actually do have a lot of versatility um
in the way they can wow you these days
i feel like there's a little bit of i
don't know it's hard to
to have a straightforward script about
the meaning of life but this one like
i think there was a draft where like he
found out that being a teacher in the
end was what really mattered to him but
they kind of
dropped that thread it is it gets a
little
weird towards the end in terms of like
what it's really trying to say because
it has a lot
that's that's kind of the difference
like one like soul like pixar's going
for this real
thoughtful like ruminative kind of depth
where it's like this really
layered complicated ideas being shared
in the
sort of format of this kid's story and
luca
goes the opposite way and it's like no
no no no no no it's about being like an
outsider and like it's a nice story
about friendship and acceptance exactly
yeah um but yeah like so the the world
that they create this like
afterlife pre-life limbo is like
it's really fascinating and you keep i
kept waiting in luca for them to do
something like that with sea monster
society it's just so hard to relate to
like the parents
and lucas predicament it's like do they
want him to like
go to ocean college or do they want him
to literally live in this cave
around this one island and that's the
only place there are sea monsters like
i just don't understand what the parents
vision for him was i mean as far as the
uh
as the lack of world building goes or
the
the shallowness of the premise it's like
is that is that a thing in italy and
like italian folklore that we just
aren't familiar with like they're like
of course the sea monster world like
like uh
where is it iceland and the and the
fairies and stuff like that
i don't think so i read a thing with the
director where he was saying they were
inspired by it
like they show some of them like those
decorations like those mosaics or
whatever
of like fishermen wrestling with
monsters and then maps they were saying
like on old maps you know there would be
like with the little
ruby monsters and they unexplored areas
like they're saying that i don't think
it's a direct line from like
italian tradition to this movie that's
not like the italian thor
sea monster or whatever you're like oh
yes the
you know the the the neurotic jewish
mother underwater with her children
just wants him to stay a shepherd don't
chase waterfalls stick to the rivers and
lakes you're used to
used
all right keep going luca
after the trailers made it look like
call me by your name for kids
prepare for what luca is actually about
a sea creature obsessed with the surface
who comes out thanks to the
encouragement of an older boy
that enters a pasta eating contest to
win a scooter they don't need and
decides he'd rather go to astronomy
school instead
is it kind of breezy and unfocused by
pixar standards sure
is it better than the last five
dreamworks movies yes
will it make you wish you were a cartoon
who gets to live in pasta town
of course it will you're not a monster
journey yeah
i mean i think it maybe just hit me at
the right time but i appreciated that it
wasn't trying to
uh tell me what my life's purpose was
that it was like remember those fun
summers here's here's one
this looks nice i guess you're just
either in the mood for that or not
um and uh i thought luca luca hit me in
that spot
i was totally in the mood for that and
made me really want some pesto it made
me want to
gallivant and remember like what it was
like to be 13 and have those summers
that you feel like are going to change
your life and then everything goes back
to normal
i'm not arguing that it's like it's a
nice movie that i enjoyed i just feel
like pixar has created these like
iconic classics of the genre and it's
not one of those
yeah i i was gonna say i i think a good
double feature with this would be the
the film side out you know it reminds me
of those fun summers when you're
working as a as a paralegal and you uh
get really into beach volleyball instead
you team up with an
aging over the hill volleyball star to
uh that's where i messed up when i was a
paralegal
not enough volleyball you need to wear a
head-to-toe massimo track suit
and play beach volleyball but it's just
we do have a massimo in this so
perfect but it would it would be like if
inside out like halfway through the
movie he also discovered a love of like
astronomy were you just like how does
this
how does this fit in with the story of
already the world
he wanted to explore the world it just
feels like there's like eight different
elements that we just kind of
jump between them it's a little it's a
little messy i don't know would have
been better if it was astrology
yes much better yeah if he got if he was
just constantly like irritating
everybody by asking about their like
signs
like it's the exact time of day they
were born what's your rising
that feel real enough to touch while all
the characters get the bean-shaped head
and noble smile of every other cartoon
made in the last 10 years
oh great now pixar looks the same too
meet new paws i i i stumbled across this
huge
controversy of the the cal art style do
you guys know about this yes oh boy yes
yeah i guess i've been blissfully
ignorant um and
mostly it's people uh shrieking about
their thundercats
but uh but when you do see it all it's
like yeah this is definitely
a animation trend that has taken hold
and
it's like i don't know you could
definitely place this as the
in line with the 2010s to 2020 style of
of character animation right sure oh
yeah yeah was it adventure time that
popular yeah adventure time for sure
like that was the first regular part of
it steven universe for sure
yeah steven universe regular show like
right now there's a whole litany you can
name that that look
kind of like that infinity train but um
i feel like
adventure time was maybe the one that
sold
everybody on all your cartoons have to
look this way now right
and i don't think that's due to a uh
conspiracy to take your sexy cats away
uh i think that's just a lack of uh
risk-taking in hollywood or rather it's
like oh this worked so let's do more
things like this that you see in
every facet of the entertainment it's
also one big
show like an adventure time a lot of the
story artists and writers and
animators branch out from that and
create their own projects
so it's not crazy that after there's a
huge groundbreaking animated show
you'd get some other shows following its
way to kind of in the same way that like
bojack and tuka and birdie like lisa
hannah animated
and designed both of those shows so it's
not surprising that they kind of look
similar like that's her
that's her style no lon it's about cat
boobs
well right yes it's also about cap
okay keep going boy who works under the
sea finding nemo's
he's this generation's version of the
little mermaid but when this fish out of
water also wants to be where the people
are he'll have to escape his jewish
italian myrmom
if i have to send you to the bottom of
the ocean to keep you safe
so be it by teaming up with mac's mom be
the guy at cards there once
you don't find me attractive no and run
away with alberto
a cartoon as free-spirited as jack dylan
grazer doing a junking interview
fire fire firefighter telling that a lot
i bought a houseboat
no you didn't yeah i did i have no money
left who is your favorite batman oh
great question
uh well there's countless i would say
george clooney or val kilmer
yeah pause i had no idea
who this guy was until i guess now it's
like oh yeah he's that kid from those
things
um but what uh what a fun interview man
people really
usually phone in junkets because they're
so tired to be there and i'm sure
he will soon two or three movies from
now but
we've got him we've got him at a really
exciting time in his life where he still
has the energy
to have fun during uh his 17th interview
with
um geekbook.biz
[Laughter]
so there's a lot to choose from i
recommend everybody watch like jack dill
grazer's best junket moments because
he's always
he's always goofing around very young to
have carved out like
a recognizable persona like he's
basically playing himself
in this movie at age like 14 15 like
that's crazy to have already established
like here's the
jack dylan grazer bit i'm gonna do like
other actors you could see being like
we're looking for a jack dylan grazer
type at this point and you'd know what
that means
like that's impressive to be his i think
i'm gonna i think at this point i'm
gonna
um uh uh justin timberlake in the
facebook came and say
drop the dylan it's cleaner just yeah
just jacklin
um all right keep going these two wet
little scamps will team up with third
wheel julia
to explore a rich world of mustache
characters like massimo
a one armed man without a tragic
backstory for his disability
what this is how i came into the world
senora marci glace
an italian entrepreneur who's not part
of the mob where you can do that
and air collate a jackass buoy without
some weepy excuse for why it turned out
that way
come on they're breaking rules i liked
that
i liked that but lon you didn't you
didn't like that there was no i didn't i
didn't feel the need for like
explain like give us the bullying
backstory
i just felt like what a what a dumb
he's cardboard he's he's only there to
be uh
an antagonist to luca there it doesn't
feel like there's an
inner life there's a real character or
there's really even a reason for him to
to be sometimes people are just jerks
lon some people are just kidding
i don't know every moment with him just
felt like super perfunctory like you
know exactly who that you're super
perfunctory
yeah sometimes people are mean i mean i
guess like i
don't think they're i don't think i can
think of a single pixar villain who's
that
cardboard thin like where it's just like
bad guy
hates everything mean for no reason
also yeah uh in addition when we're
talking about the the tropes that they
kind of avoid
two parents everyone's except for except
for
uh uh poor what's his name uh other fish
boy um
alberto doesn't have thank you alberto
doesn't have parents
but to make up for it even julia's got a
mom who lives in town like that's kind
of great
yeah yeah yeah um so there you go
it's not like i need like a crew we do
that joke but it's not like i need like
a
like a like a prequel where you know
it's like a fish killed his dad or
whatever but
i just it i i don't know i i i wanted
there to be something else to that
character you know like like
syndrome or like you know like like like
a pixar bad guy where
there there's a little there's humanity
to it even as they're the antagonists
for our here
yeah all right fair enough let's make
that drive just like hey i'm a weasel
okay you're just mean and awful you know
the movie rules
quick disney make a prequel where a mob
of fish eats dad's arm and kills the
bully's parents
phew and they better explain how he got
that sweater too
more and more more lord come on
everybody
so dive in to another pixar thing that
you could poke full of holes if that's
what makes you happy
like when you're part fish isn't this
considered murder
isn't this considered genocide and is
someone that picks our own vespa stuff
i mean we were talking about that before
we started rolling of like
i guess because like
we think the fish under the sea must all
the sea creatures must eat other fish
right otherwise
why would they kill their friend i mean
yeah he's a kurdish shepherd yeah
like that's his whole job as a fish
shepherd and then when we see them
eating they don't specifically eat fish
and i was trying to figure out if
sea cucumbers uh have a soul which i
don't think we ever landed on
i mean could it be their eggs they're
hurting fish
for their feet yeah like that like they
could milk the fish yeah
you know they like the fish how you do
like it's
like it's caviar i don't know i don't
if this is what i mean like it all just
felt kind of like well they're
they're italian so they're shepherds so
they gotta
shepherd something goat fish
you did point out it was like kind of
check out fish like they kind of set up
that this is a seafood village but no
one ever eats
seafood like he chops up fish heads and
throws them in the garbage but there was
never i guess i was too dark for kids of
like they
explicitly like serve them their mom's
head on like a platter or something or
they're like old fish dog friend's head
it seems like they eat fish and it's not
a big deal to them
but like dead fish don't terrify and
horrify them
so i would assume you could just serve
them a plate of fish
it's just weird to have the whole town
constantly catching fish
gutting and preparing fish and then
exclusively eating
uh linguine with pesto yeah like that's
the only food that they eat
it's also just stereotypical like that's
not like i know in america we think
that's what italians eat every meal
but it's like not really well this is i
also couldn't really place this in time
was this supposed to be like the
450s 50s and 60s 50s yeah
60s it's like the era where the director
was growing up in italy yeah
because i definitely had a period in
like the 2000s where i also thought the
vespa was the coolest thing in the world
however i don't drive so don't listen to
me on car stuff
yeah i also had a period in that time
where i only ate pasta
so i always just think of eddie izzard's
impression of an italian person on a
vessel
i've never been tempted by a vest but
this movie did not uh
didn't didn't push me over the edge but
they tried let's uh uh keep playing
let's see
it's just the greatest thing that humans
ever made the vespa
it's so beautiful yes we need it
wouldn't it be amazing to have a real
vespa we'd swim right over to vespa town
track down seen your vespa vespa vespa
vespa wild vespa
hey stop looking she's too beautiful for
you but it's a sweet short little film
with a nice message that you can watch
for free with your loki subscription
and in that one inevitable moment in
every pixar movie that makes you cry
at least you won't be doing it in front
of a theater full of children have fun
daddy
go back to hero daddy's remembering um
this was going to be my daughter's uh uh
first appearance on an honest trailer
but she was
asleep during the time when we needed to
do this so that's our producer uh our
producer max dion his uh
his child um joanie uh so
well done joanie that was some uh
beautiful video
apparently jody's in a phase where she
will repeat anything that max says to
her yeah
so be fortunate that we only uh
through well i think we have some some
clip to the session that we might play
during the outtakes so uh more to come
on that but yes congratulations joni
um we'll find a spot for uh for little
gilbert um
at some point soon we're on his trailer
babies uh okay keep going
hook wine and sinker peer pressure
manic pasta dream girl felici moe
maya rudolph professional cartoon mom
fish don't eat a real fish fish you know
that's why they're always frowning
they're like what's that smell
oh it's me i'm a fish and borax
subsequent movie fish well carcass
chum and summer
[Music]
worst part about this movie now i'm sad
and hungry which usually means i'm
heading straight to the oliver garden
i've never been to an olive garden have
you guys oh yeah wait uh
in your life you've never no i always
because you you can go to olive garden
here or you can go to buca de beppo
which
i'm trying to promise you is superior
even having never been to an olive
garden
i don't think the food in burgundy's
that great either but it is better than
over
yeah olive garden is where you go after
like your senior play
like if they're still open like that's
the kind of thing where it's like okay
everybody like you finished up you did a
great job on little women and now you
get to go have a never ending possible
it very much feels like if there were a
like drive-through
fast food italian like that's not a
concept but if it were like
if there were like a mcdonald's that was
like giovanni's and you just get a box
of pasta
like that's that's what olive garden
food tastes like it's just crazy that
there is
bad sometimes you're in the mood for it
but how is there not a drive-through
italian restaurant this is not great car
we can fix that this is america we can
turn anything into car food i mean you
could do like fry they do like those
fried rice balls at italian restaurants
you could do those
and then like a fried pasta ball concept
i mean there's that
uh i think it's filipino fast food place
jollibee
and they'll give you yes they'll give
you just a bag of pasta with your bread
they will
they will but then yeah if we need a
a one-hand pasta uh comment sound off on
your ideas for one-handed pasta
probably know wendy could be italian we
don't know yeah we need to figure out
that
that the in and out like will you be
dining in your car like what's the pasta
equivalent of this
we need that if you could get a single
noodle
we'll talk about this later because i
don't want to give away trade secrets on
this show
i mean they are and luca they're just
picking up handfuls of pasta and eating
it so like we're on our way yeah yeah oh
i guess we could instead of
innovating with the food we could just
lower our standards to the point where
we could just be
reaching into it
like a rotini as opposed to like a
linguine or spaghetti you know
yeah maybe like a gun that shoots
ravioli uh
i feel like americans should be into
that i think the answer honestly we all
know
for american palettes the answer is
frying it if you fry
it it becomes holdable in a hand so like
a fried ravioli a fried
macaroni a bowl italian dinner in like a
hubcap of dough and you just lower it
into the fryer oh my god
much like the crunchwrap supreme uh
which is the superior way to deliver
taco ingredient taco bell um okay like
fast food big night
well
it's just the entire drum and everybody
just takes bites out of it
um all right keep going or no that's it
trailer yeah let's let's see some delete
scenes and maybe a little uh
joanie special feature asks audiences to
consider
what if two fish boys had a fun summer
together
really that's it and the hero has two
living parents
are we sure this wasn't sony luca
oh great now pixar looks the same too
this is the wrong lesson to take away
from anime
joe got mad at it
johnny splash cff little orphan alby
santa craft singles gargamel
mama maya and ali seashow
spaghetti westerd the shape shift of
water
splash fiction finima paradiso
if the parents are convinced humans are
gonna kill luca why are they constantly
trying to reveal them in front of
everybody
what's wrong with that you gotta get
that dick daddy
what's wrong daddy
what's wrong daddy daddy
okay great let's try again later yeah
that take three was good
perfect yeah yeah i hope we use take
three yeah that's great
uh it's it's awesome and terrifying that
kids will
just like do whatever you say at that
age uh well within reason like they're
the temptation for me to say like bush
did 9 11
she learned it herself i don't know yeah
i think about the um
kung pao quote a lot uh we trained him
wrong as a joke
as a parent and consider it but now
we'll teach her how things really are
i'll teach her about the world of the
actual world
give her tools to thrive take her to the
olive garden
yeah you shouldn't take her to the
olympia i know i informative experience
yeah definitely formative for both of us
all right um this is normally where we
would uh
answer comments and questions from the
commenters does anybody have any
comments or questions
because i'm fine to just not do that and
go have uh reclaim our time
i honestly think claiming our time i
honestly think the biggest one that the
fans would have asked honestly
you answered which was the like why you
didn't do a pixar movie like a soul but
did do
this one i i do think people wonder like
why we don't do solar cocoa but you
already kind of explained that one
so to predict what i did did we i i
don't have a full explanation on that i
just think whatever spencer emails me
yeah i don't know and i do whatever uh i
i'm just trying to be popular i do
whatever people are talking about right
now
unless there's a good reason to do
otherwise and uh
i'm sure at the time there was something
more popular than seoul
well seoul opened on it came out on
christmas day so we were
on we were also on vacation and by the
time we got
back i guess presumably we were just
like um by the time we got back we must
have just been like ah there's so much
to do
coco might have been the one where we
look at it like i don't know what to do
with this because i find pixar
movies though this one was easy enough
but pixar movies to be the most
difficult to
make jokes about because they're really
good and they also
are cartoons so you can't really talk
about the logic of them because like
it's a cartoon and it's
ostensibly made for children i know toy
story 4 was a really tough one
because it's it's self-aware and it's
funny and it's poking fun in itself so
it's the fourth one yeah like what are
you gonna what are you gonna say
you know yeah um so they can be really
tricky uh and then coco
we of course like people have been mad
if we didn't
uh do original music covers or at least
of you know the big songs from that one
and it's just like you know what let's
just do demolition man in fact let's do
demolition man
um have we not ever haven't done
demolition man which is crazy
so that's going on the schedule after
this yeah but but
too late uh because we can't completely
decommit for what we do have coming up
next week
yes which uh is something that i think
for us trailers it's going to go
completely off the rails but
we hope you enjoy it it'll be different
um and if not
don't worry i'm sure we'll do loki after
that or something
we've got we got a month left but then
yeah yeah exactly
uh all right thanks everyone for
watching assuming you are um
we don't know this is uh this is the
past and i hope the future is treating
you just as well
lon danielle thank you for joining me
see y'all soon bye
[Music]
you